après plusieurs années de captivité avec
des milliers de proches combattantes du
groupe armés et tes islamique 23
Canadiens proviendront bientôt au pays
ce qui réjouit la mère de Jack let's
party en Syrie en 2014 alors qu'il était
âgé de 18 ans
la Cour fédérale a ordonné vendredi le
rapatriement de quatre Canadiens qui
sont actuellement détenus dans le
nord-est de la Syrie
la veille Ottawa a autorisé celui de six
femmes et de leur très enfant 23
Canadiens dites nous en Syrie à
l'exception de Jack let's sont
représentés par Maître green Spon à son
avis le rapatriement était inévitable en
vertu de la Charte canadienne des droits
et libertés et s'il devait y avoir des
accusations criminelles à leur endroit
le processus pourra se faire dans un
contexte plus juste on peut les
poursuivre ici à Canada il peut avoir
une procès juste au lieu de laisser ses
hommes et les femmes dans les prisons et
dans les camps de détention sans
accusation mais comme leur crime
potentiel aurait été commis à l'étranger
difficile pour le gouvernement canadien
d'en faire la preuve d'après cette
expert en sécurité donc c'est une
capacité quand bien une bonne partie de
nos alliés l'Australie la France
l'Allemagne le Pays-Bas les États-Unis
le Royaume-Uni mais au Canada on en a
pas outre les aléas avec la justice
il est aussi la prise en charge
psychosociale de ces Canadiens
considérés à haut risque selon les
autorités
et souvent pour les plus grands ils ont
vécu la guerre avant donc des
bombardements être pris dans des
situations de tir et de guerre souvent
perdre un papa ou des personnes qui sont
proches tous les très difficiles et très
traumatisant selon l'organisme human
weight watch certains auraient été
victimes de traite de personnes et ce
serait retrouvé dans les rangs du groupe
armé et à islamique alors que d'autres
auraient rejoint les rends du groupe
jihadiste de façon volontaire ici
Gabriel prout Radio-Canada Montréal